okay so you want to be a good
residential architect
but you've kind of lost your way here
are my five
tips to get you back on track so tip
number one
is relatively simple let me come around
to the couch
is listen to your client if you're able
to listen to your client and genuinely
pay attention to what they have
to say you're going to get a much better
outcome
both for yourself and for them now i say
it this way
because we don't want to redraw his
architect 100 times to get it right
and some of the time it is genuinely our
fault for not listening to the client
so if you're able to listen to what they
have to say and
interpret and understand what they've
said
you're much more likely to be able to
design something
that is exactly what they're looking for
now as well as being able to listen to
the client
very intensively it's also your job
to communicate with them on a very
personal and humble level
residential clients especially luxury
residential clients
pay a lot of money to be able to deal
with an architect one-on-one and to be
able to get
your insight and your knowledge so if
you're able to communicate with your
client
on a very personal level get to know
them get to know their marriage get to
know their family
this is going to result in a much better
outcome for both you
and the client and your next client
thanks to the great marketing strategy
of word of mouth
okay so we completely skipped the intro
so what's going on guys
my name is david thomich and welcome
back to the channel i've already spoken
about it and today we are talking about
top five tips for residential architect
the tip number three is very very
critical
and it is important to understand from
the get-go point number three
is understanding budget if you're able
to understand budget you're going to be
able to successfully design something
that the client wants
and be able to retain that all the way
through to build
the last thing you want to do is for
your client to come to you
and say hey david i've got a budget of 1
million dollars
sweet this is going to be a good project
and then you turn around and design them
a 4.5 million dollar mansion that they
can't afford it goes out
tender it gets tendered and the builders
give you that ridiculous price point
one your client is gonna be furious two
you're gonna have to redraw all that
for free and three you're gonna look
like an idiot so
make sure you understand budget and
understand it well
if your client comes to you with that
one million dollar price tag or even
900 000 for argument's sake and you know
in the back your head
the last project you did which is
roughly the same cost about
three thousand dollars a square meter
this is a figure i'm pulling out of my
head
don't use it in real life then you know
that you can go ahead and design
roughly a 300 square meter property
for these clients that's going to cost
900 000
to build when it comes back from tender
it might come in
just under just over but a 10
contingency
is kind of normal in the industry so if
you're
able to be able to design within the
budget within the contingency
you're going to have very very happy
clients now for argument's sake
this is where you actually get paid to
do your job with that three thousand
dollars a square meter we go on to tip
number four
be innovative you need to be innovative
where you spend the money
you don't want to go and blow all your
money on some
ridiculous marble staircase that's
tucked behind the corner of a lift shaft
you want to be able to spend that money
where people are going to see it and
enjoy it
so make sure that you go out and
uniquely
and thoroughly design every space so you
get the best bang for your buck
i know that's a generic saying but it is
very important to be innovative
in design and when it comes to budget
and last but not least
is tip number five as you've probably
already become aware
working with residential clients is very
personal it means you spend a lot of
time getting to know them and they spend
a lot of time getting to know you
so something that you may inadvertently
do is over promise
that's something everybody does every
now and again and as long as you can
deliver on time
it's okay but you're going to come to a
point in time where something goes wrong
and you can't deliver and a client's
going to be upset
so make sure you always under promise
and over deliver
it sounds very simple but it is very
difficult to do in practice
especially when you're running 10 to 20
different jobs concurrently so if you
can under promise and over deliver to
your clients they're going to be very
very happy
and you're going to seem like the hero
every single time that being said if you
need to tell your client you need a week
to do this job tell them you need a week
and a half
i know you're probably not going to need
that week and a half but it gives you
that little bit of
relaxed time just in case anything goes
wrong anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching the
video i hope you enjoyed it
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below help this
video with the youtube algorithm if you
want to see more of my content
smash that subscribe button down below
because as always
i will see you next monday